and then when the Marxists say well that
wasn't real Marxism what it really means
and I've thought about this for a long
time it's the most arrogant possible
statement anyone could ever make it
means if I would have been in Stalin's
position I would have ushered in the
damn utopia instead instead of the
genocide of massacres because I
understand the doctrine of Marxism and
everything about me is good it's like
well think again
sunshine you don't understand it you
don't understand it and you're not that
good and if the power was in your hands
assuming you had the competence which
you don't you wouldn't have done any
better and even if you had there would
have been someone else waiting right
behind you to shoot you the first time
you actually tried to do anything good
and that's what happened to all the old
guard who ran the damn Revolution Stalin
rounded them all up and shot them along
with their families and millions of
other people so even if you do happen to
be that avatar of moral purity that you
claim implicitly the probability that
you get to act out your goodness in
relationship to those possessed by your
ideology is zero